facebook is banned in china google is
also banned
but airbnb isn't i wanted to know why
china allows airbnb to operate when it's
banned so many large american tech
companies
so i dug into the history of airbnb and
their operations in china
to figure out what it takes to grow a
truly global tech company in the 21st
century
and what i found really surprised me
airbnb is a great lens through which to
view u.s china relations
and in this video i'm going to show you
the china loophole
how it relates to airbnb's history and
what it means for the future of american
technology companies in china the
chinese economy is expected to be the
biggest in the world in just a few years
after all
so this is really important stuff if
you're traveling to china
you'd need a vpn just to watch this
video that's because youtube is blocked
by the great firewall
which prevents anyone in china from
accessing basically any website or app
that the government doesn't have
complete control over
instagram pinterest and snapchat are all
blocked
but airbnb isn't which struck me as odd
since airbnb is a very typical tech
company they were founded in the bay
area
they're listed on the nasdaq and all
three founders are american citizens
but airbnb has employed a few key
strategies to allow them to succeed in
china where so many have failed
understanding the choices that airbnb
has made shines a light on how the
chinese communist party thinks about
america
in general so let's figure this out
together
if you're new here i'm john coogan a
startup founder based in los angeles
california
and on this channel i analyze the
strategies of successful technology
entrepreneurs
i put out new videos weekly so please
hit that subscribe button and ring the
bell so you don't miss out
china has an entirely unique set of
rules and regulations when it comes to
internet businesses
taking a business model that's working
in the united states and expanding
internationally is often alluring
because of how many new customers you
could gain if you have product market
fit domestically
launching that same product in a foreign
country seems like an easy way to grow
your business
but china is unlike any other country in
the world
see china is a one-party state led by
the chinese communist party
and the government enforces strict rules
around what can be done on the internet
in america you can spin up a new startup
with little more than a landing page
but expanding your venture into china is
a lot more complicated
airbnb has taken three key steps to
maintain compliance with the chinese
government
and each one showcases the benefits and
costs of expanding into china
the first hurdle in any american
company's way is the internet content
provider or
icp license icp is kind of like the
golden key that opens the gate
and allows you inside that's airbnb's
former senior legal counsel stressing
the importance of this license
without it you literally can't put up a
single web page in china
and it's far from a simple process you
need a local law firm in
china to help you with the filings and
have your web hosting provider
vetted by chinese authorities this is
not just any business license you can do
within you know 21 days this
takes all teams airbnb is a big company
though
so they clearly have the resources to
set up a team in china to handle this
but the specific structure they use to
build their chinese division
is unlike any normal corporate structure
and here's where it gets really weird
under chinese law foreign ownership in
most chinese industries is prohibited
companies like alibaba
aren't allowed to have non-chinese
shareholders but there's a workaround
it's called the variable interest entity
or vie
and this is really the heart of the
china loophole a variable interest
entity is essentially just a shell
company the entity is set up to hold
all the assets the company owns in china
but because of chinese law
the entity isn't technically owned by
the controlling company
so airbnb created one of these variable
interest entities to operate in china
but it doesn't own a single share of it
instead there's a complex web of legal
agreements between airbnb
and their chinese counterpart that gives
airbnb
a claim on the profits belonging to the
shell entity but there is no recognition
of any actual
ownership this model was actually first
developed by enron
to perpetuate a massive fraud at the
turn of the millennium and it has major
risks
if you've seen the recent volatility of
chinese stocks on american exchanges
it's all because of the vie structure
because airbnb
lacks clear control over their chinese
operations
there's a chance that laws could change
and they could have to forfeit
everything very quickly but this is
essentially just the cost of doing
business in china
when you can't own shares in a chinese
company it's basically impossible to set
up a proper subsidiary
like you would in canada or mexico these
laws make rapid expansion into china
extremely risky
and as we've seen most american tech
companies fail to gain traction in china
airbnb was willing to undertake the
challenge of getting an icp license
and setting up a variable interest
entity but that doesn't explain why
china let them advance through these
stages undeterred the reason
is that china cares a lot more about
censoring information on social media
than restricting commerce and airbnb
isn't really used for spreading
information
like facebook and twitter are one of
airbnb's investors put it really well
i think media and commerce are two
separate categories as you know media is
a lot more regulated and there's a lot
more
oversight in that part of the internet
value chain whereas commerce
cross-border commerce are being promoted
by chinese government essentially
if you want to do business in china
you're going to have to hand over your
data
and censor information that the chinese
communist party doesn't want spreading
this requirement has proven to be
insurmountable by many tech companies
google famously pulled out of china
entirely after refusing to censor search
results but airbnb's business
isn't built on data and censorship isn't
much of an issue
so these chinese rules are much less
harmful to their core business
in order to understand how airbnb
operates and the real reason why they
actually stand a chance at launching a
successful china operation
we have to go back to the company's
founding
in 2015 brian chesky the founder of
airbnb
stood on stage with xi jinping at a
global technology summit
but just eight years earlier he was a
broke entrepreneur
looking for a way to pay his rent it was
2007 and brian was living with his
future airbnb
co-founders although he didn't know that
at the time he had graduated from the
rhode island institute
of design and recently decided to move
to san francisco to pursue the dream of
building a startup this is october 2007.
i get to san francisco and joe tells me
the rent is 150
i didn't have enough money for rent that
weekend this international design
conference
was coming to san francisco we went to
this conference website and we noticed
on the conference website they had like
a hotels tab we clicked on the hotels
tab and next to every hotel said sold
out
sold out sold out and at that point we
just had this idea we said well
designers need a place to stay we
literally have no money in fact i don't
know how i'm gonna make rent so we
thought
what if we just created a bed and
breakfast for the design conference
so they created the first airbnb ever in
their own apartment
the idea didn't take off immediately but
after testing the idea again
at a few other conferences they began to
think the idea had traction
beyond saving money on hotels and being
able to find a place to stay on short
notice
airbnb created really strong
relationships between
hosts and guests when most people travel
they want to get to know the city that
they're staying in and have an authentic
experience
by staying in an airbnb a tourist would
have a local contact
and get recommendations about what to do
in town and it's this idea of building a
community and sharing culture that
really drives airbnb to expand globally
airbnb's mission is to
create a world where anyone can belong
anywhere and in order to achieve that
mission
airbnb has to be available in every part
of the world
even if that expansion comes at a very
significant cost
but it's also in airbnb's financial
interest to expand globally
even more so than other tech companies
this is because the short-term vacation
rental market
has a global network effect it's a
winner-take-all market
because people who use airbnb while
traveling from new york to san francisco
will also want to use the service while
traveling abroad and this became a
really critical strategy for the company
early on in their journey
the first few funding rounds for airbnb
were pretty small by silicon valley
standards they joined y combinator in
2009
and received twenty thousand dollars in
exchange for six percent of the company
the entire global financial system had
just collapsed and america was still
recovering from the great recession
so startup valuations were definitely
depressed as brian went out to raise
money for airbnb
after demo day he wasn't getting a lot
of attention it was still difficult for
venture capitalists to wrap their minds
around the idea of staying on an airbed
in a stranger's house
but one venture capitalist knew there
was something special here
greg mcadoo at sequoia capital saw
something unique in brian and his team
they had grit one of the biggest
concepts paul graham
and really the entire y combinator team
tries to instill in the startups that
they fund
is this idea of staying alive far too
many entrepreneurs raise money and then
spend it all
over a few months expecting that they
will be able to raise more it's critical
to instead focus on keeping your startup
alive for as long as possible
by any means necessary the airbnb team
had scraped by for years doing whatever
it took to make ends meet
they just refused to call it quits
during one particularly rough stretch
they decided to capitalize on all the
hype around the 2008 election between
barack obama and john mccain
leveraging their design backgrounds the
team put together custom cereal boxes
with each candidate's name on them
and sold them as collector's items at
the conventions even though this wasn't
a scalable business
and really had nothing to do with airbnb
directly they made 25 000
and were able to keep the company alive
for a few months longer this story
clearly resonated with paul graham who
accepted airbnb
into the 2009 yc cohort and when greg
mcadoo asked pg
what team had the most grit it was an
easy answer
that willingness to grind it out when
times were tough
allowed airbnb to survive long enough to
raise more money
and i think this determination is a big
reason why airbnb has been able to
overcome
so many challenges in china brian and
the airbnb team were able to raise a 600
000
seed round after demo day and quickly
followed that with a 7 million
series a in 2010. these are pretty
typical figures for young startups
and are even a little low by present day
standards but airbnb
series b round was where things really
changed they raised a massive 112
million dollars from andres and horowitz
and the reason was clear airbnb had to
go global
a group called rocket internet had
launched an airbnb clone in europe
called whimdu
and this was a major threat to airbnb's
long-term plans
within three months of closing the
series b airbnb had opened its first
international office in london airbnb
wound up beating wimdu and established a
strong foothold in europe
but asia would be another matter
entirely airbnb wanted to create a
flywheel of guests becoming hosts
and vice versa people would start by
using airbnb while traveling for work
like what happened at that first design
conference but then they would start
using it for vacations the more they
traveled using airbnb
the more likely they were to list their
own home on airbnb
when they had free space leaving
international markets up for grabs was
extremely risky
if american travelers wound up using a
different app while traveling abroad
they could easily wind up using that
same app while traveling domestically as
well
if one country stops using airbnb there
could be a domino effect in other
countries
china is the final frontier in airbnb's
plan to become a truly global company
and in order to win airbnb has to be a
great experience for both
chinese hosts and chinese travelers
abroad
here's airbnb's co-founder explaining
their full rationale
chinese travelers are the biggest
spender on international uh
tourism so it's a huge outbound market
that's nate blitchardzik
he's a co-founder of airbnb and the
chairman of airbnb china
and he's a really critical part of the
story when he says
outbound market what he means is chinese
tourists staying at airbnbs while abroad
but there's a second critical piece to
airbnb's china strategy
more than 50 percent of our travelers
going to destinations in asia are coming
from china
and so by attracting chinese guests from
china
we're actually helping to grow our
business in japan
and thailand throughout asia other tech
companies can afford to cut ties with
china
if they don't have as strong of a global
network effect but losing china
may cause airbnb hosts in japan or
thailand
to switch to a competing service which
could cause a domino effect when a user
decides to list their home on airbnb
they want to be sure that any traveler
no matter what country they're coming
from
can book a reservation without any
issues and that's why china is so
critical
airbnb clearly needs to maintain
operations in china their entire asia
business depends on it
but sharing customer data with foreign
governments is a tricky
issue that is starting to play a bigger
role in the national dialogue
chinese apps like tiktok have come under
fire for collecting data on u.s
consumers
while ultimately answering to the
chinese government as airbnb has grown
their operations in china
they've had to make compromises about
the way that they handle customer data
since 2016 airbnb has told users that it
shares information with chinese
authorities
phone numbers email addresses and in-app
messages are all made available to the
government
when you check into a chinese airbnb but
this doesn't really surprise me
i was in china a few years ago and just
assumed that the government could see
anything that i was doing on my phone
and i expect most airbnb guests
traveling in china would assume the same
while i would never want to live in a
place that restricted personal freedom
and privacy to such an extent
i don't think there's much that a
company like airbnb can do about it
nate blecharzick actually made headlines
last year when the wall street journal
reported that he had said
quote we're not here to promote american
values
that can seem callous like he's someone
that doesn't see privacy as universal
right
but i think he's just doing what's best
for airbnb ultimately
pulling out of china would mean
sacrificing not only their chinese
business
but much of their asia business more
broadly and it wouldn't do anything to
change how privacy is handled in china
local competitors would just step up to
fill the void while gladly giving full
access to their data if you'd like to go
a layer deeper
just enter your email on johncoogan.com
and please check out this recommended
video
the youtube algorithm thinks that you'll
really like it